hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going to be starting a new
kind of video series anna will be going
over and covering each and every single
individual technique that the wonderful
world of just youtube kaizen holds for
us in this first video i'll be going
over all the current barrier techniques
that have been revealed to us so far and
explain exactly what they are of course
if you want me to go more in depth on
just specific barrier techniques like
reggie's new one perhaps then make sure
you let me know in the comment section
below after the video and i'll be sure
to get on to it and also if you are new
around here then make sure you hit that
subscribe button as well as it really
helps with pushing my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people but anyway enough
of that let's get into the video so as
the name suggests barrier techniques are
techniques that allow the user to erect
and manipulate barrier walls they can be
used to conceal entire areas shield
people or trap opponents among various
other uses barrier techniques are the
simplest and most common curse technique
as they require no innate talent to
utilize so pretty much anyone with
enough cursed energy can learn to erect
barriers such as the non-combatant
jiu-jitsu high managers that purposely
place a curtain barrier around sorcerers
when they battle so that the public
doesn't notice the curses or sorcerers
inside now it may seem that barriers are
extremely basic however advanced barrier
mechanics can be complex even for the
most talented jiu jitsu sorcerers many
strong users with innate techniques
can't even perform basic barrier
techniques for example creating a
barrier is simple enough but making it
so only certain people can exit requires
advanced skills it goes even further
than this as well as one step above this
is the sphere of domains which are an
extension of just a simple barrier
technique intertwined with the
sorcerer's innate ability but more on
them in a little bit the first of the
actual barrier techniques that we have
is called the curtain this is a commonly
used barrier technique that separates an
area using a black force field that is
invisible to outside observers it only
requires a minimum level of skill to use
however a few powerful sorcerers
apparently do not possess this ability
making it in some regards rare the
difficulty of the technique varies
depending on the complexity of the
curtain and because of this other less
skilled sorcerers may be able to create
barriers that are only useful for hiding
things from the public whereas skilled
sorcerers may be able to implement
specific conditions to their curtain to
hold or delay a person or people inside
the entire method in regards to
conjuring up one hasn't been completely
revealed as of yet but when deploying a
curtain you must utter the words emerge
from darkness blacker than darkness
purify that which is impure as we saw
with mojito early on in this story at
this school once deployed if the user
was able to cast a strong enough barrier
it would not typically be able to be
destroyed with brute force however they
are still able to be destroyed a barrier
can be taken down where the sorcerer who
created it is killed or just physically
beaten to the point they release the
barrier however to get around a beating
curtains may be created and imbued in
objects which then maintain the barrier
until that said object is then destroyed
when it comes to the domain versions of
a barrier we have the three most
commonly known types which are simple
domains domain expansions and domain
amplifications however there are
actually two subtypes of domains which
are extremely unknown and used by a very
limited amount of people the first of
these two is the falling blossom emotion
which is an anti-domain barrier
technique and a secret art passed down
throughout the big three sorcerer
families the falling blossom emotion
shrouds the user and an armor of curse
energy that counter-attacks the instant
a domain's guaranteed hit makes contact
the cursed energy defends the user
automatically countering any attack with
equal force to nullify it when the
ability is applied to a defensive sword
stance not only is the user shrouded in
cursed energy but their sword is as well
this allows the blade to automatically
strike anything the curse energy comes
into contact with usually dealing a
final and fatal blow the second subtype
of a domain is called the hollow wicker
basket this is an ancient esoteric
barrier technique and is a predecessor
to this simple domain this ability sets
up a small basket-like barrier around
the user which neutralizes the barrier
of a domain in order to negate the
guaranteed hurt however as we found out
with reggie and his battle against
megami the barrier doesn't help with
incomplete domains which do not have a
guaranteed hurt at some point the
concept of the hollow wicker basket was
refined in order to create this simple
domain the new shadow style simple
domain is an anti-domain barrier
technique that erects a small shield
around the user to protect them from the
effects of a domain expansion
simple domain was invented as a counter
to the domain expansion
if it gets deployed within no domain the
cast of the simple domain will not be
affected by the imbued curse technique
of the opponent's expansion or the
automatic hurts while one domain is
deployed inside of another the cast of
it will be vulnerable to attack so
simple domains can also be used
offensively throughout the story there
are also several swordsmanship
techniques within the new shadow style
that operate around countering anyone
who enters the range of the user's
simple domain so this one here isn't
really seen that often as well but
domain amplification is similar to the
simple domain but it surrounds the user
in a fluid aura as if they were
surrounded by water the chance of the
user's attacks missing aren't improved
but they will always neutralize any
technique they come into contact with
the caster of this technique though
cannot activate the domain amplification
or the innate technique at this time
this is most likely due to the fact that
the water around the user probably
nullifies their own attempts at creating
an expansion
so finally the most powerful and supreme
barrier ability introduced so far
throughout the series the domain
expansion so this works by using a
curtain-like barrier to create a
separate space the user can then realize
the innate domain within the cursed
energy and trap their target within it
the domain is then imbued with the
user's innate technique to complete the
formation of it inside of the barrier
the user's jujutsu is greatly amplified
and any attack deployed is a guaranteed
hit to anyone caught inside when
activating it using a hand sign or
another sort of signal unique to the
technique is one of the requirements to
bring the domain forth as we find
constantly with megami throughout the
series manifesting an innate domain with
curse energy requires a lot of power and
erecting a barrier requires even more so
even though megami is one of the
strongest characters he can still not
erect a barrier to fully complete his
domain
as said it's an extremely difficult
technique to learn that most high-level
sorcerers are never able to master like
most other techniques domains aren't
solely used by jiu jitsu sorceries as
well and some high-level curse spirits
mainly only special grades like maheso
hanami and jogo who have been shown to
use the ability can use their domain
expansion
so that brings us to the very end of all
the currently known jujutsu kaizen like
barrier techniques that have been
released to us throughout the world so
far obviously i honestly have no idea if
we're going to get more for all we know
we could get a ton more honestly
throughout this uh calling game that is
currently going on as we could say with
like reggie how he was introduced with
his barrier technique which was the
precursors to the simple domain which is
a well-known like barrier technique
throughout jujutsu cars and used by a
lot of the kind of like lesser stronger
people i guess you could say who are
still strong but they just can't fully
use the domain i guess is probably the
best way to put it obviously i love how
all of the kind of barrier techniques
work against each other and work with
each other in specific ways how like the
simple domain or like the hollow wicker
basket that reggie has will work against
kind of like a full domain to protect
the user of the kind of like barrier
inside the domain and that all
originates from the very first like
specific just curtain i like how it all
kind of like originates back to that
very basic idea of just needing to
summon a cursing the whole idea of
barriers originating from that gives it
like kind of like a purpose and like you
can see how people would have
experimented over time and then
developed these different kind of
techniques from that original kind of
like uh barrier technique that they
needed to have but yeah obviously if you
guys have any ideas of what series and
what kind of like techniques or
abilities you're gonna go over next i'm
thinking of doing all of the families
and explaining explaining like all of
the families different techniques that
they have next and then after that
probably going over all of the innate
abilities throughout all the jiu-jitsu
kaizen so obviously there are a ton of
innate abilities so that video is going
to be quite a long one but there's only
a few families so i'll try and get this
family's video out next week for all of
you guys who are interested in that but
anyway obviously as i've just said make
sure you leave a comment down below and
let me know what you guys thought of the
video and what you guys
and what you guys want to see up next
and also make sure you hit that
subscribe button if you are around here
as it really helps out with pushing my
stuff to a bunch of new amazing people
but for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i will see you
all in above bye